plus important que définir ce qui est
heureux qui est un peu abstrait c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire là chacun
d'entre nous aujourd'hui pour essayer
d'être un peu plus heureux voilà ça
c'est je pense que c'est ça la vraie
question parce qu'après on va se perdre
dans des trucs philosophiques et
qu'est-ce qui nous empêche d'être
heureux aujourd'hui de prendre le temps
de se demander peut-être on se met trop
la pression peut-être on s'enconce en
coupable on a l'impression de pas en
faire assez et donc de se voir à quel
point on finit par croire plein de
choses qui nous empêchent de revenir à
tout ce qui est déjà heureux dans notre
vie qu'on ne s'autorise pas à
reconnaître à aimer donc je pense que
c'est peut-être déjà la première chose
mais si on est concret il y a des gens
voilà c'est très compliqué le 15 du mois
et ça peut trop bien comment finir le
moi et est-ce que on peut dire à ces
gens-là
à ces gens là on peut voilà c'est
franchement c'est la merde on va pas se
mentir mais il y a peut-être un moyen
d'essayer de voir les choses plus
positivement j'ai un doute mais
si on attend pour être heureux que tout
aille bien
moi c'est ce que mon père me demandait
souvent est-ce que tu es heureux et je
me souviens d'où je m'angoissais je me
disais mais j'avais tout de suite
l'image du couple au bord de la piscine
tout souriant heureux les enfants
courent faire leurs devoirs il pleut
jamais mais ça c'est pas dans la réalité
dans la réalité ça n'arrive pas donc il
faut peut-être se libérer de cette idée
que pour être heureux il faut que tout
soit parfait et pour tout le monde il y
a les fins de mois difficiles il y a des
angoisses il y a l'impression de pas
être à la hauteur il y a trop de
pression je sais pas si quelqu'un n'a
pas tout ça donc être heureux c'est
peut-être apprendre à faire face à la
réalité trouver qu'il y a des solutions
parce que au fond le problème c'est
qu'on a l'impression qu'on est coincé et
qui a pas de solution et si j'ai écrit
mon livre c'est vraiment pour dire pour
montrer aux gens qui a pas de fatalité
on peut toujours essayer de faire de
voir qu'est-ce qu'ils nous empêche
d'être heureux relativiser voir
qu'est-ce qui nous fait qu'on se sent
coupable sans raison apprendre à entrer
davantage en relation je crois que
ce qui nous empêche d'être heureux c'est
l'idée qu'il faudrait être dans le
contrôle total ça correspond à cette
image parfaite alors maintenant
moi je suis heureux et je me retrouve un
peu dans ce que dans ce que dans ce que
dit Fabrice parce que j'ai appris j'ai
appris en fait à même dans la difficulté
à chercher ce qui est bien ce qui est de
bien et puis et puis me contenter de ce
que j'ai surtout et par contre j'ai
appris quelque chose parce que on
parlait de le 15 du mois justement on
dit que l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur
et ça j'ai un peu de mal avec cette
phrase justement alors parce que
l'argent ne fait pas bonheur certes mais
aujourd'hui sans moyens c'est très
compliqué quand même si on est très
malade c'est difficile d'être heureux si
on n'a pas d'argent c'est difficile
d'être heureux si on se fait quitter par
son conjoint c'est difficile d'être
heureux donc la question c'est comment
on fait pour alors comment faire parce
que
par exemple quelqu'un du mois c'est très
compliqué et que sa femme s'est barrée
on achète le livre
par exemple ce qui est frappant c'est
que ce qui rend heureux c'est d'entrer
en relation c'est créer du lien c'est
d'avoir du lien avec les avec les arbres
en ce moment parce que c'est la nature
avec nos amis avec notre conjoint en
demandant aux gens qu'est-ce qui vous
rend heureux cette semaine les gens
disent tous des choses moi à la fin du
livre j'ai interrogé plein de gens
qu'est-ce qui les rend heureux alors ils
disent voilà je venais de rentrer d'un
séjour à l'hôpital et j'ai pris le temps
caresser mes chats et c'est ça le moment
on sent le lien et j'aime beaucoup cette
phrase parce que on confond le bonheur
et le bien-être
tout va bien on est heureux parce qu'on
sent que ce qu'on fait ça a du sens on
en adéquation avec soi on sent que c'est
vrai moi dans le livre raconte qu'un
jour j'ai un de mes amis qui allaient
très mal j'ai dû l'emmener à l'hôpital
le soir je suis rentré j'étais heureux
pas du tout parce qu'il a les mal j'ai
je me suis angoissé mais j'avais
l'impression de faire quelque chose qui
avait du sens vous savez des je l'ai
aidé j'ai eu l'impression de faire
quelque chose qui avait du sens donc je
crois que c'est très libérateur de se
dire non le bonheur c'est pas un état
parfait c'est pas un état de bien-être
c'est quelque chose où je me sens où je
me sens
du lien de la relation un vrai numéro
seul et est-ce qu'elle peut être
heureuse
par exemple pour être heureux de
reconnaissance de lien depuis on est des
animaux sociales et quand on sent pas du
tout de reconnaissance quand les gens ne
nous parlent pas qu'on se sent méprisés
c'est très difficile mais comment on
peut apprendre par pour soi-même de
devenir son propre ami comment on peut
se donner à soi-même de la
reconnaissance beaucoup de gens est-ce
qu'on peut être heureux sans amour
non mais on peut pas être heureux sans
amour sans aimer
qui peuvent vivre heureux qui peuvent
être heureux en étant seuls ah oui mais
c'est pas seul ça veut pas dire sans
amour parce que vous pouvez voir de
l'amour pour vous pour vos amis pour vos
parents pour vos enfants pour les
animaux donc ok tout le monde il faut
pas être normatif parce que ce qui rend
aussi les gens malheureux c'est l'énorme
il faudrait être comme ceci il faudrait
être comme cela faudra avoir tel visage
on va avoir tel comportement alors là
vous êtes c'est ça qui rend les gens
aussi très malheureux être heureux c'est
peut-être accepté aussi qu'on est
imparfait accepter qu'on est des êtres
humains c'est pour ça je suis heureux on
est tous imparfait personne et où
personnellement parfait oui mais vous
êtes l'exception
du rôle du doudou oui alors doudou moi
j'en ai un quand j'étais petit j'appelle
ça la ma doudoune d'ailleurs c'est une
petite peluche qui a fini à la poubelle
bah en fait
laver dans le lave-linge et là la
peluche
en fait elle est morte j'étais très
malheureux comme un peluche a été noyé
par ma mère dans la machine
de montrer en parlant de ça c'est
l'enfant a besoin d'un doudou pour
sentir en sécurité nous on est on est
adulte c'est plus un doudou mais
qu'est-ce qui nous permet de se sentir
de la sécurité qu'on a tous besoin on
vit dans un monde qui anxiogène et je
donne plein de conseils pour voir
comment faire de chez soi comment
trouver sa place comment trouver des
points d'ancrage qui nous donne cette
sécurité qui fait qu'on a moins peur du
risque et de l'aventure et l'être humain
pourrait être heureux il a besoin de
deux choses un espace de sécurité de
confiance et pouvoir faire des choses
partir à l'aventure risquer et c'est
l'équilibre entre les deux qui rend
heureux
qui apaise ou qui font du bien moi par
exemple j'ai une photo de Jack togea un
acteur qui est sec
[Musique]
le plus beau pour moi de la terre
regarde
non chacun pour soi faut pas se moquer
on a tous des choses un peu absurdes qui
nous aident à nous en créer ça peut être
une plante ça peut être qu'est-ce qui
nous aide et donc ce qui est important
c'est de sentir que il y a toujours
quelque chose qu'on peut faire très
simple qui nous aide à voir que on peut
retrouver du souffle on peut retrouver
de l'espérance on peut retrouver de la
lumière et c'est ça que j'essaie de
montrer parce que beaucoup de gens ont
l'impression qu'ils sont foutus qui sont
fermés dans leur histoire beaucoup de
gens ont vécu des histoires difficiles
moi j'ai une enfance difficile on des
fois on a l'impression que j'ai pas été
aimé j'ai vécu un trauma je suis foutu
pour toujours et je vous l'ai montré non
il y a pas de on n'est pas foutu il y a
toujours la possibilité de faire quelque
chose de transformer nos difficultés
un des premiers qui a on va dire
démocratisé la notion de la résilience
et effectivement
j'imagine que pour toi ça t'a parlé
énormément parce que
les épreuves étaient voilà et se dire
que ça un sens aussi on n'est jamais
enfermé dans quoi que ce soit il y a
toujours la le bonheur est un est un
mouvement la vie est un mouvement et
apprendre à entrer dans le mouvement
c'est trouver des manières d'être apaisé
de sortir des aussi parce que
qu'est-ce qui vous a si je peux faire
qu'est-ce qui vous a rendu heureux dans
les 15 derniers jours un moment qui vous
a rendu heureux dans les 15 derniers
jours
moi j'avoue j'ai de la j'ai de la chance
j'arrive à trouver à trouver tous les
jours quelque chose qui me rend heureux
donc voilà c'est une des techniques de
Monsieur pour moi le bonheur ça se
construit
et ben je savais que j'allais venir à
l'émission voilà ça c'est un grand
bonheur
moi c'est mon chien qui remue la queue
de plus en plus souvent
dans la montagne il y a d'autres chiens
des moutons etc et du coup je vois qu'il
a une nouvelle jeunesse
franchement
c'est qu'on voit que c'est le fait
d'entrer en lien en résonance vous êtes
touché par l'animal l'animal est touché
par vous il crée un lien quand on
demande à la plupart des gens qu'est-ce
qui rend heureux on va dire voilà c'est
ceci il faut potentialiser ceci il faut
mieux contrôler ceci on est toujours
dans le contrôle mais quand on écoute
les gens comme nous on voit que c'est
pas du tout ça c'est le fait d'être
touché de sentir que ça a du sens et je
crois que c'est c'est en fait une grande
un grand changement de Para on a demandé
moi quelque chose je crois le plus
naturel en tant que maman franchement ce
qui m'ont heureuse le soir vraiment
quand j'ouvre la porte bah je suis hyper
heureuse de retrouver mon fils voilà
quand vous ouvrez la porte qui a
personne
ça y est quand elle me dit ah tu es là
parce qu'elle m'appelle maman maintenant
et ça ça me rend heureux parce qu'elle a
l'air tellement heureuse
c'est le lien de la relation et c'est
sûr que on oublie ça on est tellement
pris toutes nos journées par faut que je
contrôle davantage les choses j'ai trop
de pression je fonce davantage alors
qu'il y a des remèdes anti burnout qui
sont très simples à mettre en place
alors Jean-Pascal qui est toujours très
bah voilà qu'est-ce qu'ils vont heureux
ah non mais ça vous paraît bizarre mais
alors moi je suis l'homme le plus
chanceux du monde parce que tous les
matins je me lève et je me dis je suis
en bonne santé et je me lève et c'est
tout et je suis hyper non non mais c'est
pas une connerie
le matin j'ai la chance de voir les
montagnes chez moi et cetera je me lève
le matin je me dis on est bien et
ben ça me rend heureux moi je me dis mes
enfants mes enfants mais c'est vrai ils
ont pas faim ils ont pas soif
quand j'ai pas d'argent je suis pas bien
évidemment la santé des proches
évidemment le le si le travail ça se
passe bien mais en vrai quand t'as pas
d'oseille
par exemple le 15 du mois parce qu'on y
est tous confrontés quand le banquier la
paye en découvert et cetera ouais mais
si on regarde six mois à vivre le
problème de largeur le problème de
l'argent tu vas pas avoir de problème tu
vas te dire je vais pas pouvoir résoudre
la maladie tu ne peux pas bébé mais ça
c'est toujours des solutions
je voudrais parler d'argent oui on parle
dans un instant ah d'ailleurs niveau
argent je pourrais prendre le livreur si
vous voulez améliorer votre univers et
en fait prendre les choses en fait du
bon côté je ne serai que trop vous
recommander le livre de Fabrice Midal
voilà tout ce qu'il faut connaître pour
être heureux merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]